hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from around 1 this
time of the wind or saib rapid to
challenge its Hikaru Nakamura versus
Erica rockin already there's a c4 on the
board sorry about that and I would just
like to mention one thing before we
check out the game on this Saturday
there will be a charity tournament on
Leech s it will be a chess marathon if
you will 24 hours of non-stop chess so
everyone is welcome to join there are
already 15 grandmasters in the
tournament so you you can also join you
might get a chance to play against them
now the organizers of this tournament
contacted me they are they've created
this tournament as a means of gathering
funds for the mercy or maybe it's a
mercy hospital in Metz in France so they
get our funds so they can get our more
funds for the hospital to help them out
and if you want there will be a link in
the description below that will lead you
to determine Tinley chess you can
already register if you want to play but
also below that I will put a link at the
website where you can learn more about
this cause and you can you are welcome
to the donate to their cause if you are
interested in that so that being said
let's check out this game and also I
might stream some of the games on
Saturday from this event so now if you
if you by any chance get a game against
one of the one of the grandmasters it'd
be pretty awesome to stream that but
yeah getting back to the game like I
said Nakamura vs. area Kraken and
Nakamura opens with c4 yeah sorry about
that
which you've already seen on the board
with Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and now
II five with Knight to f3 Knight to c6
or the four Knights of the English and
now blacks usual idea is just to bust
open the center with d5 but nakamora
prevents that with E 4 he goes for the
names of each variation which prevents
black from executing d5 but on the other
hand it kind of loses the control of the
d4 square so yeah you know it's a you
give some you you you get some we have
the ship to be for now correct in a
threatening to pick up the knight and
then just pick up the e4 pawn so d3
adding a defender to the pawn and now d6
by Kerrigan
we have a three asking do you wanna
trade or do you want to go back with the
bishop so here a bishop the c5n out be
for grabbing more space on the Queen
side the shop to be six and now the
immediate Knight to a4 Nakamura is
basically playing against blacks dark
square Bishop he wants to eliminate it
and when the bishop pair early on so
Bishop to g4 carotene continues
developing and now just Knight captures
and b6 with a cap Tristen b6 so Nakamura
was able to eliminate a cariocans dark
square Bishop also double his double his
beep on but on the other hand correctly
now has a semi semi open file for his
rook which is also very useful so Bishop
to b2 Nakamura continues development and
now Knight to d7 may be preparing f5 at
some point we have Bishop to e2 just
continuing development preparing to
castle and it's interesting correcting
most likely prepared specifically for
this game because nakamura already had
this position in the 2019 US
Championship against Samuel 7 where 7
played castles in this position and
Nakamura was able to win that game but
here our Kerrigan goes for h5 and it is
a new move so already as of move 11 we
have a completely new game
Nakamoto continues by castling and now
Queen to f6 now saying that I might
Castle queenside I might Castle kingside
I might just continue pushing on the
Kings side with the g5 characters in g4
it's it's a new position so anything is
possible
nakamura immediately offers a trade of
light square bishop s' we have bishop
characters queen characters and now
Knight to d4 and this is an excellent
outpost for the night and Nakamura's the
dark square bishop isn't really doing
all that much so of course nakamura
decides the trade at the characters
captures and now f4 as the e5 pawn is
gone so c5 now just striking that b4
pawn at some point you might want to
play rook to e4 to add more pressure to
the to the attack and now Knight to f3
Knight to f3 offering the f4 pawn but
it's it's unclear whether it's it's good
to capture it or not so you might just
decide
so you might go rogue day for to put
pressure on the b4 pawn there are a lot
of ideas here but Carter connects
actually goes for the pawn with Queen
captures an f4 now he doesn't win a pawn
here it's basically a trade but what he
gives Nakamura is a much more active
square for the knight so here are
Nakamura grabs the d4 pawn opens up an
attack towards the Queen Queen e5 and
now Knights the b5 going after Knight to
c7 check but kurakin not interested in
this he just castles King side and he
says your knight will not be very useful
and be five but Nakamura disagrees his
Knight is now nicely guarding the a3
corn so he can shift the rook into the
game with rook 81 at some point even d4
might be an idea
so g6 by Carrick in preparing to make
the position a bit safer for the King
may be playing g7 also at the g6 pawn
now guards the h5 point so you can move
your Queen Queen to f2 by Nakamura and
now King the g7 and now rooked III
preparing to bring another attacker to
the f7 pawn so here
rook to a for now going after the b4
pawn and here you could go rook to f3
attack the pawn and then f6 but you will
still have to deal with some of the
threats on the Queen side so instead
Nakamoto goes Queen to d2 right away
adds another defender to the b4 pawn
here and now Queen to e7 by Sergei might
might have something to do with him
wanting to the x-ray that'd be for pawn
at some point maybe I moves like DF I
will be possible with it then then
trying to grab a pawn on b4 however very
unlikely so I don't really see the point
of Queen to e7 yeah but okay nakamura
continues with d4 which is excellent you
want to open up this diagonal also if
the Queen can come to d4 it will be it
will be really great for example if
captures captures with check King h7 you
can go Knights for c7 and it will be
just just a very strong position the
Queen Knight is now coming to see it to
d5 then you'll have a lot of pressure on
f6 add the rook can come to g3 it's just
gonna be a very tough position to defend
for black
so after d4 we have Kings to h7 by
Sergey and now rook eita f3 now adding
more
the f7 pawn and I was Sergei again moves
the King with King to g8 but now even
though it looks like black is perfectly
fine and defending the position is
actually lost so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the winning
maneuver for white while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on spotting an excellent move with the
knight back as a wise man once said that
the hardest move to find is with the
knight back and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
it's Knight to c3 it's always hard to
find because you always think about
going forward instead of going backwards
but the point is now of course if you
capture the pawn then just 95 wins the
game the Queen is under attack and also
you just lose the rook after the Queen
moves so Sergei went back rook 88 but
still Knight to d5 now attacking the
Queen saying that you should grab my e4
pawn the problem with grabbing the pawn
here on e4 is that rook f4 forces the
Queen back and you don't have good
squares for the Queen for example you
only have east 6 and e8 if you go to e6
rook e1 just traps the Queen no more
squares for the Queen and if you go back
with Queen to e8 then you can just ruin
material with Knight to c7 which of
course forks the the Queen and the rook
or you can even just go rook e1 attack
the Queen and after the Queen moves just
a nice rook to e7 which puts more
pressure on the position threatening
ideas like rook actress and night and
after the Queen recaptures Knight f6
check pics of the Queen and it will be
impossible for black to hold this so
Cara can of course not going for d4 pawn
he goes Queen to h4 and now comes Luke
to f4 also a possibility was just Queen
to h6 and then rook f4 but Nakamoto goes
for it right away
rook at 4 attacks the Queen Queen back
to d8
and now comes Queen 2 f2 adding a third
attacker to the f7 pawn so f6 by kurakin
now defending as the knight also nicely
defends it but now Queen g3 going after
the g6 pawn which was just weakened so
King h7 but now e 5 finally the
breakthrough in the position that white
needed D captures on e5 d captures on e5
and now there is no good way to continue
the game you could
you could advance the pond to five you
could capture with the night but all of
these options are bad for example if you
capture with the pawn rook f7 check is
deadly for example captures captures
with the Czech king h6 and now Knight c7
and there's no defense Queen g6 is
coming you cannot defend as the night
also guards that if you push the pawn
than just Queen b3 and there's no
defense against either of the two mates
so that's what happens if you capture
the point if you advance the pawn then
you just give white a brutal a past epon
attacks the night after the knight moves
east 7 just wins the game or or you
don't move the knight and then you just
give up a piece so Karen went with the
only other option which is the capture
the pawn with Knight characters on e5
but now comes Luke captures on f6 as the
knight and rope nicely defended Kerrigan
decided to go for rook to e8 to defend
the knight on e5 but again it doesn't
work so once again for the last time I
feel free to pause the video and win
this game for Nakamura
well I'll give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations as it's not an easy
move to find and for those of you who
just wanna enjoy the show it's rook to
f7 check and it was also in this
position that Sergei Cara can resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here our point is yes black can
capture the rook however if you go for
Knight captures on f7 you get rook
captures on f7 with check now of course
if you go here than just Queen captures
with check guards the rook and delivers
checkmate so you'd have to go either to
h8 or h6 and both of these plants fail
miserably
for example if King h8 then Queen the c3
check King has to move or you can start
giving up some pieces but all in all you
will have to move the King and then it's
just Queen g7 checkmate so what's left
after rook captures an f7 is just king
to h6 but now it's Queen and now it's
Queen to f4 check Queen to g5 and now of
course a nice rook h7 check which wins
the Queen King characters Queen captures
here and there is nothing more to be
done here
so Sergei calculated all of these all of
these variations out after rook to f7
check and of course it was in this
position that he resigned the game
yeah a nice game from round one and an
excellent victory for Nakamura before we
forget here are the standings a nice
cross table from chess 24 website so
sharing first place are these four
gentlemen Hikaru Nakamura Magnus cross
and Sergey carotene and Wesley so
followed by Dingley ran with two and a
half points then we to Alexander Grecian
Levon Aronian
und with one and a half and then with
one points we yunxi stuff do that the
kneeled above and ali reza future so
there you have it like I said if you
enjoy you know chess do check out the
links in the description below one to
the elite chess tournament where you
will be able to face off against some
grandmasters and the other link where
everything is explained in French but
there is also a section in English so
don't worry and if you are interested in
helping them out do consider
contributing so once again I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Mariam
Koloff William Reed out Mario ensino
salud spare and the fame chick
incorporated for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the OL
indoors ABI rapid challenge checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you I will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day